it's that lovely time of year where we
watch all our favorite holiday classics
and then realize something that's always
bothered us about them like is it okay
that Tim Allen may have murdered Santa
Claus is die hard a Christmas movie no
but my personal favorite is Santa Claus
a complete jerk in the 1964 Rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer special and are we
okay with it
Rudolph Rudolph please could you tone it
down a bit
I mean that nose of yours sure Santa's
just trying to do his literal
one-and-only task of the year which is
making Christmas happen but he sure
keeps the workplace insufferable for two
separate departments yes and the
reindeer department Oh can I eat that
silly elf song is driving me crazy so
let's start with the elves these all
spend 365 days of the year building toys
for kids around the world I guess they
have no vacation days while Santa gets
most of the credit for just like
overnighting the packages once a year in
addition to their hard-earned hours the
elf spend what seems like a lot of time
carefully crafting a song about working
for Santa called we are Santa's elves
that's like me showing up to work on
Monday and call my boss into a
conference room with a song called I am
Cynthia's producer that's my supervisor
and honestly I'm not against writing a
ballad about it but it's still a lot of
work to coordinate an entire song when I
am NOT by nature a songwriter anyway I'm
getting away from the point the elves
invite Santa to elf practice to hear the
latest version of the song and then he
has the nerve to show up very
impatiently and say and after they're
done performing their song about being
dedicated to no one else but Santa he
gives them feedback and acts like they
wasted his time mm well it needs work I
have to go
what does Papa know is it part of their
Elf contract to perform for Santa was
this just like an extra thing they did
after hours either way I'm not okay with
it moving on Department number two the
reindeer
great bouncing iceberg now I'm sure
it'll stop as soon as he grows outside
well let's hope so if he wants to make
the Slade team someday so CEO tells her
freak off he'll never make the Slade
team unless he can get rid of the nose
that is attached to his body and then he
tells her doll father that he should be
ashamed of himself you should be ashamed
of yourself
walk up Pippy he had a nice
yeah well harsh there Kris Kringle now
this movie in particular is what causes
Rudolph to run away from home and almost
died a bunch of times and then when he
returns Santa has just canceled
Christmas because there's a storm in the
North Pole which happens a lot and he's
still annoyed at Rudolph for no reason
until he has this major Epiphany that
nose of yours that knows that Christmas
is not off and you're going to lead my
team oh I can use yeah yeah freak now
weirdo takes the high road here and goes
along with it but I would have gone down
on the low road like this SNL moment wow
wow Congrats oh you could put that away
Donner whatever your name is okay I've
been pretty tough on Santa this episode
and I want to make the nice list so I'm
gonna highlight the like one good thing
he does and by the way you've watched
pretty much every single moment that
Santa shows up in this movie because
he's not a lead character and he's
barely there at the end because he feels
terrible probably Santa let's Rudolph
guide him to the banished island of
misfit toys which are toys that are like
slightly off because Santa doesn't like
anything different and then he picks
them up he gets there and they're crying
if I hope I'll never get off this island
at their banished and he picks it up and
gives him a home great this is like the
last 10 seconds of the movie
well let's be on our way so in
conclusion am i okay with rude Santa
yeah I am not because I agree with his
actions but because it's pretty funny to
realize that the villain of Rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer is somehow Santa
Claus you know the most beloved figure
of all time so let me know do you have a
favorite rude Santa moment or do you
completely disagree and find that
Santa's actions are completely justified
they're not well let me know your
thoughts and your suggestions for the
next episode of are we okay with this
you can find me at Ashe Cross
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]